this is you and this is your life with
your sad iphone battery yeah your
battery sucks literally and it makes a
ton of sense for you iPhone 6 owners
after 500 charging cycles the iPhone
battery can lose up to if not more than
20% of its original capacity and it's
around this point that this guy says so
should I buy a new iPhone right now the
answer no no no no it's my annual advice
summer means no iPhone buying wait until
the fall when the new models come out
and the old model prices drop so what do
you do until then you choose your own
battery repair adventure the hard medium
or easy way let's start with the hardest
bust the most affordable way yes it's
time to put on the lab coat some goggles
and replace that battery yourself all
you'll need is about 30 minutes of time
this $20 iFixit repair kit and another
device so you can read the instruction
oh and you'll need a lot of dexterity
and patience when I say this is hard I
mean it you have to remove the tiny
screws from the outside of the phone top
off the screen then remove more tiny
screws then pry the battery out by
removing annoying adhesive strips then
you pop in the new battery and reverse
the process more than once I panicked
that I was going to break the whole
thing and I sort of did for a few
minutes it felt great when I was done
but it is not for most people it worked
you don't really need the lab coat or
the goggles by the way but please be
safe and careful when handling the
battery and then dispose of the old one
properly don't want to do that all by
yourself go with the medium option and
pay someone to do the hard work for you
yes the hardest part of this step is
getting up and going to the Apple Store
Best Buy or your local repair shop
you'll have to find something to do why
the geniuses do their work but $80 an
hour later I walked out of the Apple
store with a working battery too lazy to
even leave the house I cracked will beat
that price by $20 and come right to you
hold on
in ten minutes you did what I did in 45
minutes
pretty much great plus the tech
discovered the real reason my friends
battery wasn't charging lint broke and
now for the easy and the lazy strap
another battery to your phone yeah it's
ugly super ugly but it works for 4.7
inch iPhones my top picks are the $100
Apple smart battery case or the $60
anchor ultra slim extended battery case
both will buy you more juice in a mere
battery replacement although the Encore
requires a separate micro USB charger
see that wasn't so bad now go enjoy that
brand new healthy battery and if you
remember anything don't buy that iPhone
right now hope